kaye west is having fun with cheney
jones you know the model who looks
eerily similar to his estranged wife kim
kardashian you know i think you have to
have a sense of humor a source tells e.t
the relationship is by no means serious
and quote kanye it's mostly spending
time with cheney as a publicity stunt
just
just do something for my heart yay and
cheney were first seen together earlier
this month stepping out for dinner in
malibu at the time the 24 year old's
looks immediately had fans doing a
double take as she bears a striking
resemblance to the beauty mogul it's a
different experience for sure and chaney
shared this snap to her instagram story
on monday as a pair of vacations in
miami simply captioning the selfie with
the black heart emoji the source also
tells et quote cheney is having fun
hanging out with him and enjoying all
the cool things they're doing together
all the while kim isn't welcoming her
estranged husband's antics
you just gotta roll with it the reality
star filed to be declared legally single
in december and now in court docs
obtained by e.t last week kim says quote
kanye has been putting a lot of
misinformation regarding our private
matters and co-parenting on social media
which has caused emotional distress and
i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for us the
reality star seemingly references yay's
instagram post on valentine's day he
kicked off the day by sharing these
images showing a truckload of flowers
delivered to kim's house
but the social media post took a sharp
turn
he shared screenshots of alleged text
exchanges with kim
one message even showing her asking
quote why can't you keep any of our
conversations private also in the court
docs kim believes terminating their
marriage status will quote help kanye to
accept that our marital relationship is
over and to move forward on a better
path which will assist us in peacefully
co-parenting our children meanwhile kim
and boyfriend pete davidson are only
getting closer oh my god a source tells
e.t the comedian has been quote going
out of his way to connect more with
kim's family in his own subtle ways
he wants to show them who he really is
and have the family get to know him
better and pete's efforts might be
paying off one member of kim's inner
circle bestie jonathan chubbin voiced
his support for the new relationship as
one of kim's closest confidants what do
you think of her and pete together um i
think it's cool yeah you know what she's
having fun i guess you know uh you know
i i've hung out with them a couple of
times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy ask her friend
how are you supporting her through all
the kind of the kanye craziness that's
happening oh i don't even know anything
about that so i love kanye too man he's
a genius excuse me um but you know
listen i just i hope i hope everybody um
ends up settling
[Music]
you